no I just started okay hello and welcome
to this video playing the Reaper man I
hear some bogus text in there it doesn't
have the real name okay so we come and
show me what you can that's probably but
corny anyway so what is he going to do
the Reaper man after screen d7 bishop
age 3 IDM okay it's directly aiming is
play against it okay i mean i can click
when you're seven provoke him to play g4
or this one then that make sense I just
want I mean something like 95 doesn't it
doesn't do all that much maybe I can
still just develop I mean you still
cannot Castle bit of a strange shape a
strange way to play the opening but
doesn't look all that bad so maybe a 6b
five is on the agenda he would probably
yes do this something that I maybe
should have looked for a little bit more
closely anyway he still cannot play
castles which is a good thing and the
move like g4 always has its drawbacks
yes I yeah I have to take with the gig
with the bishop but that isn't all that
bad I don't think it's that bad Queen B
5 is uh is an annoying move I just one
day and maybe just plays Bishop f1 or
something like that and I actually can
play night XD form it's annoying anyway
push up m 1-93 for should work him so 97
however he has visual f1 I would like to
trade this night eh 497 this is what I
would like to play ok I'll go here I
mean if he goes Bishop f1 Queen B form
should be possible sorry voices a little
bit of
[Music]
so let's let's get this straight going
not sure it will take but it's quite
sensible pre-move so that should not be
bad really not I've traded down to this
yeah bishop aged three years what he
wants to do understand the blame so
let's check get rid of stuff so take
here
that's not easy to play should be
obvious a little bit a little bit tricky
so if I've before maybe melted to shut
mb5 before I is also somewhat weakening
I can also bring the rook around like
here rook a 6b 6b form might be an
option ok I definitely want you prevent
if five maybe that was still still not a
good move order anyway anyway we'll see
yeah you cannot play before I take ok
form just work at the moment maybe I
should have played be five actually oh
ok for before but whenever I go beef
what why is that possible or is the
second no you don't understand it looks
afore i have be five
you might get a passer which which could
be dangerous but objectively it should
not work for wide what's going on here
[Music]
this move I actually overlooked it's bad
so night 86 after look before that it's
not ideal for him
would be three why isn't that forced
it's not playing this quickly yes
playing time morning is playing for the
mating ideas that's great great stuff
yeah take here and now it's going this
is what she wants to do and you should
be six it's going to be quite dangerous
it's not yet a maid so this one we
should be 6 all the way to age 64 I'm
not sure I have to have to play have to
play a move
check-check
Kenneth was g5 and then me check there
might be some other mates now no check
no Bishop f5 I am nicely nicely done and
we can play these six now okay matte
black forfeits on time very very strong
[Music]
maybe the engine defends it but for me
it was enough so let's see here 96 this
one check and b5 no yeah I feel like by
candlelight 65 come on that's crazy you
five is just rubbish I go yet win ah
come on that's easy I mean probably I
can take i-95 is just easy I mean I was
expecting check this normal stuff check
then this is what I was thinking and he
always has an avi of course I mean the
only question is can i wrote this or not
trophy her tricky stuff you five is just
a blunder 95 and that's really that's
just winning because he has no entry
anymore absolutely no entry to my
position okay check check check check
and notice oh no
I should just check it's crazy and I
should have five is again pretty easy
and winning now gather were many ways to
win this actually at the end yeah
probably nothing much happened here I
wonder when did I actually got this big
overtime disadvantage it was all fairly
okay check check took a while here it's
still it's two minutes check is actually
ok I mean I've here I took a long while
to figure out if I'm losing or whatever
rugby six and then it was it was just a
pretty bad miss I think you played that
very interestingly I giving out this
pawn I mean you didn't eat you I had all
kinds of things Kings before why does a
bit better him maybe more than a bit if
it gets to be five yeah ok guys thanks
for watching